there's so many good characters of
course pod is one of them and you in
chat with loads of fantastic characters
while on the show we're asking if I'm
saying what they think their favorite
moments have been with Joffrey so far
because he's one of those characters
that we all love to hate doesn't he well
I don't think it can you can get away
from when he decides to swing the sword
then and kill me at the end of the first
series I think that it's just the way
Jack performed that as well it was
terrifying you know and for such a young
guy to do something like that it's very
very impressive the whole performance to
be honest I don't think there's a weak
Lincoln and what he does is he's very
switched on and he's very very good and
that's certainly a family isn't it that
you have to deal with with Tyrion and
tired and thirsty turians the nicest um
I think so far isn't he what about
Cersei no and Tywin would have even your
favorite bits from those guys the
relationship between Podrick and Cersei
so far has been entirely seriously gives
them a look he runs away terrified so
it's funny because me and when I get on
very well off Tywin when he when he
raids then on on horseback and like what
a very heroic and finally we've had
George or Martin tell us recently that
there's a possibility of a game of
Thrones movie what do you think about
that and what would you like to see it
involved I think it's very fitting for
such a big project to end on the silver
screen if that's what was to happen and
I think it would be it would be exciting
and quite quite cool to be involved in
um but I don't know I just think
everybody's hoping for the conclusion
that they're hoping for you know what I
mean it's hard to describe it's hard to
pick something at this time but that
will happen I'm sure
you